- What I hope to do in this video is
to just read a SAT Reading
Comprehension passage with you.
And when you're actually doing the SAT
you're obviously going to read it silently
and you're going to
try to read it quickly,
but with good comprehension,
but it might be useful to just
read it out loud together,
and I might just kinda
think about how I think
about the different things
before I try to actually
answer the question.
So let's start.
"This passage is adapted from Ed Yong.
"Turtles Use the Earth's
Magnetic Field as Global GPS.
"Written in 2011 by Kalmbach
Publishing Company."
Alright, this is exciting.
How do turtles use Earth's
magnetic field as global GPS?
And that's actually
something I like to do.
I like to convince myself that I'm very
excited about what I'm about to learn.
And in this case, I actually am.
"In 1996, a loggerhead
turtle called Adelita
swam across 9,000 miles
from Mexico to Japan,"
That's impressive--
"crossing the entire Pacific on her way.
"Wallace J. Nichols
tracked this epic journey
"with a satellite tag."
So they're using satellite
tags to track it.
"But Adelita herself had no
such technology at her disposal.
"How did she steer a
route across two oceans
"to find her destination?"
So this seems like a pretty big question.
How does a turtle, with
no GPS, without any
navigation devices, go across 9,000 miles
from Mexico to Japan?
This is interesting.
"Nathan Putman has the answer."
Well that's good, someone does.
"By testing hatchling
turtles in a special tank,
"he has found they they can use
the Earth's magnetic field",
so they're using the
Earth's magnetic field,
"as their own Global Positioning System."
Wow, so they're using the
Earth's magnetic field
as their own GPS.
"By sensing the field, they can work out
"both their latitude and longitude
"and head in the right direction."
That's amazing.
"Putman works in the lab of Ken Lohmann,
"who has been studying
the magnetic abilities
"of loggerheads for over 20 years.
"In his lab at the
University of North Carolina,
"Lohmann places hatchlings
in a large water tank
"surrounded by a large grid
of electromagnetic coils.
"In 1991, he found that
babies started swimming
"in the opposite direction
if he used the coils
"to reverse the direction
of the magnetic field
"around them."
This is impressive.
So this is how they were able to tell
that the turtles use a magnetic field
as a way to tell what direction to go to,
because if they reverse
the magnetic field,
then the turtles swam in
the opposite direction.
"They could use the field
"as a compass to get their bearing."
Let's keep going.
I actually am interested in this.
"Later, Lohmann showed
that they can also use
"the magnetic field to
work out their position."
So not just the direction,
but they can also work out their position.
"For them, this is literally
a matter of life and death."
Yeah, if they go to the
wrong place they might die.
"Hatchlings born off the coast of Florida
"spend their early lives
in the North Atlantic gyre,
"a warm current that circles
"between North America and Africa.
"If they're swept towards the cold waters
"outside the gyre, they die.
"Their magnetic sense keeps them safe."
So if they go a little bit off track
into the cold waters, they'll die!
Outside of the gyre.
"Using this coil-surrounded tank,
"Lohmann could mimic the magnetic field
"at different parts of
the Earth's surface.
"If he simulated the field at
the northern edge of the gyre,
"the hatchlings swam southwards."
Yeah, they don't want to
go into that cold water.
"If he simulated the field
at the gyre's southern edge,
"the turtles swam west-northwest.
"These experiments showed
that the turtles can use
"their magnetic sense to
work out their latitude--
"their position on a north-south axis."
So they could work out their latitude,
their position on a north-south axis.
If they had the magnetic
field at the south end
of the gyre they go north, northwest.
If they're at the north end
of the grye, they go south.
They don't want to get out of that thing,
'cause then I guess the
water's gonna be too cold.
So that's how they can figure out
how north or south they are.
Now, where is my mouse? There it is.
"Now, Putman has shown that
they can also determine
"their longitude--their
position on a east-west axis."
Well, how do they do that?
"He tweaked the magnetic
tanks to simulate the fields
"in two positions with the same latitude",
so, the same latitude, latitude
is how far north-south,
"at opposite ends of the Atlantic.
"If the field simulated the west Atlantic
"near Puerto Rico, the
turtles swam northeast.
"If the field matched
that on the east Atlantic
"near the Cape Verde Islands,
the turtles swam southwest.
"In the wild, both
headlings would keep them
"within the safe, warm embrace
of the North Atlantic gyre."
This is amazing.
"Before now, we knew that
several animal migrants",
so animals that travel,
"from loggerheads to reed
warblers to sparrows,
"had some way of working out longitude,"
longitude is how east-west you are,
"but no one knew how.
"By keeping the turtles
in the same conditions,
"with only the magnetic
fields around them changing,
"Putman clearly showed
that they can use fields
"to find their way."
So this is the crux of what they're doing.
By keeping the turtles
in the same conditions
with only the magnetic
fields around them changing,
Putman clearly showed that
they can use these fields
to find their way.
"In the wild, they might
well also use other landmarks
"like the position of
the sea, sun and stars.
"Putman thinks that the
turtles work out their position
"using two features of
the Earth's magnetic field
"that change over its surface.
"They can sense the field's inclination,
"or the angle at which it
dips towards the surface.
"At the poles, this angle
is roughly 90 degrees",
and if you imagine this is
the Earth right over here
and if the magnetic
field is doing like this,
this is what they're saying, the magnetic
field is doing like
this, the magnetic field
is looking like this,
I'll just keep drawing it.
So they're saying that at the poles
this angle is roughly 90 degrees.
So at the poles, this angle is 90 degrees.
"and at the equator, it's
roughly zero degrees."
You see it right over here.
The field lines are parallel
to the surface of the equator,
while they're going into the surface
of the earth at the poles.
"They can also sense its intensity,
"which is strongest near the poles
"and weakest near the equator.
"Different parts of the world have
"unique combinations of
these two variables."
Different parts of the world have unique
combinations of these two variables.
"Neither corresponds
directly to either latitude
"or longitude, but together, they provide
"a "magnetic signature" that
tells the turtle where it is."
This is fascinating.
So we have some diagrams
right over here that says,
"Orientation", and it's
hard to read, it says,
"Orientation of Hatchling Loggerheads
"Tested in Magnetic Fields."
So, West Atlantic, this
is their orientation.
The East Atlantic, this
And then they have a description.
"Orientation of hatchling
loggerheads tested
"in a magnetic field
that simulates a position
"at the west side of the
Atlantic near Puerto Rico",
on the left, so that's
that one, "and a position
"at the east side of the Atlantic
" near Cape Verde Islands", on the right.
"The arrow in each circle
indicates the mean direction
"that the group of hatchlings swam."
So, they do the mean, 'cause
they might not all swim
in the exact direction,
so the mean gives us
kinda the central tendency.
"Data are plotted relative
to geographic north",
which would be zero degrees, and you see
where on their east side, near Africa,
they're going to swim away from that
to the south, southwest.
And then when they're on the west side,
they swim away from that, so they swim
to the north, northeast, just like that.
So this is fascinating, so
that's us reading the passage,
and obviously I read it
much slower and outloud,
which you wouldn't typically do
when you're taking a standardized test,
but I think we understood
what's going on there.
They were able to establish that the...
You know, it's a big question.
How are these turtles able to go
9,000 miles without a GPS device?
And they were able to test
and they had the hypothesis,
"Hey maybe it's the Earth's
magnetic field, that they can
"sense how it's different in
different parts of the Earth",
and then they were able
to test that by simulating
Earth's magnetic field at
different points of the Earth
and seeing what the turtles
did, and the turtles did
what you would expect them to do.
They behaved in ways that would keep them
in the right direction as they migrate.
So, now that we, I think,
have really digested
the article, let's see if
we can answer the questions.
And actually, I haven't
seen these questions yet.
I like to do this as fresh
as possible so it simulates
what you might go through when you're
going to take a test.